it's late 2008 and I'm in Kurdistan Iraq
for a political science field trip we're
driving on a long drive back to the
capital one afternoon when we stopped to
stretch our legs at the base of a gently
sloping grassy hill and as I get out of
the bus I look around to see if there's
a good spot to have that granola bar
I've been saving and something catches
my eye losing out from under the rocks
on the hill are several foot wide
streams of a thick brown mud like
substance and as I approach it to take a
closer look our guide as if he's read my
mind
shouts don't eat that that's oil my
first reaction disgust I was a student
of environmental risk active in
international climate change conferences
I knew for a fact that oil was bad but
as I stared at this foreign brown
substance fascination took over isn't
oil black what was it doing here had an
accident happened seeing this natural
oil seep made me realize that I was
completely out of touch with oil and
from this moment forward oil something
that had seemed so clearly black and
white to me took on many shades of well
brow now stick back to the first time
that you saw oil I bet that it was in a
leak of some sort and that it was bad
news it might have been motor oil
dripping out from under your car more
likely though it was on the news
oil spilling out the side of a tanker
it's downright devastating but all can
do to the environment isn't it those
images of blackened beaches wildlife
drenched in the stuff and battling to
breathe through it I was horrified to
see how in Nigeria forests rivers
livelihoods of thousands have been
poisoned by leaks in over 4,000 miles of
pipelines crisscrossing the Niger Delta
but perhaps freshest in our minds
the BP oil spill from 2010 that sent
over 3.2 million barrels gushing out
into the Gulf of Mexico over the period
of three months now 3.2 million barrels
that's 130 million gallons I'm gonna try
and put that in perspective that's
enough for you guys seated in the back
two rows to get three Starbucks Grande's
every day for the rest of your long
lives and pass that gift card down for a
thousand generations that's a lot that's
would be a lot of coffee now fast
forward a few years and the student of
environmental risk is now a consultant
often often for the oil and gas industry
now in the eyes of many Californians and
certainly many students here working
with or for Big Oil is considered the
single most uncoolest job you could have
it's really the antithesis to being the
coveted tech entrepreneur but it's not
just uncool it's seen as deplorable
total strangers will take it upon
themselves to educate me about my
malevolence and that of my colleagues
well-meaning friends and family will say
is that ethical shouldn't we get you out
of there as if I need rescuing because
I've clearly forgotten to factor in
morality into my daily decisions and on
the one hand I really do appreciate the
honesty but on the other these comments
sting every time why because it's
hypocrisy and lacks nuance where nuance
is true you see on a personal level the
130 million gallons that's built out
during the BP oil spill the thousand
generations worth of Starbucks is a lot
and certainly the destructive power of
that amount of oil is severe but from
the perspective of consumption what's
built out over three months is only an
eighth of what we consume in a day in
the u.s. an eighth and it's not your
neighbors it's us you and I who are the
consumers and as consumers our thirst
for oil is insatiable
even when we see the images on TV but we
don't like to think of ourselves as
consumers so oil remains black to us but
imagine a world without oil in it
there'd be no asphalt some fertilizers
wouldn't exist we'd have no gasoline no
jet fuel and that's already a stretch of
the imagination now try to imagine a
world without plastics everything from
toothbrushes to television screens has
either oil or gas as the critical input
in its production process for me a world
without oil would probably be a lot like
the late 1800s when oil was this new
thing that could make so much happen
much like smart phones are now actually
and smart phones driven by arguably the
john d rockefeller of our times Steve
Jobs have revolutionized the way we
organize ourselves and communicate with
each other certainly I am very thankful
for my art iPhone and I'm very dependent
on it but getting a phone into the hands
of every person on the planet has a
price there are environmental issues
associated with the extraction of the
minerals required and if it's true that
Apple's manufacturer had to hang nets
below its laborers dorms to prevent them
from committing suicide
that doesn't attest to the great labor
conditions in the electronics industry
but are we disgusted when we see the new
iPhone no in fact if we were to meet
someone from Apple at a cocktail party
we'd say something along the lines of Oh
Apple is it I'm a big user of Apple
products myself but we never say Oh
excellent is it I'm a big user of oil
products myself
my point is rarely is anything that
truly rocks the foundation of society
like oil like smartphones all good or
all bad and oil whilst it certainly has
a dark side when the risks manifests
themselves
it still feels the economy literally and
it's not so black and white
for example I'm pretty sure that you
feel great when you can fill up your car
for under $2 a gallon at the pump and
you're not alone because the average
American household will save around $750
this year because of the drop in the oil
price and that's great news but the drop
in oil price also in dangers the 9
million jobs in the oil and gas industry
in the u.s. that's one in 20 jobs a
similar contradiction reduce dependence
on foreign oil is a prominent highlight
that any president would love to boast
with in their State of the Union but in
casual conversation we condemn the shale
gas boom that almost single-handedly got
us this independence whose side is she
on you might be thinking I'm rooting for
accuracy and fairness in debate in a
world of highly polarized media and in a
community we're really taking a stance
is often rewarded I invite you to join
me on this uncomfortable space in the
middle let's go all out on renewable
energy and energy efficiency but also
recognize that oil is really doing
something for us in the meantime let's
hold the oil industry to really high
standards but also respect the people
who work in it because the dismissive
treatment of oil just seems like a form
of hypocrisy when most of us don't
really walk our anti-oil talk are we
really doing all we can to reduce our
oil footprint things like reducing the
amount of plastic we use and waste
fighting for teleconferencing facilities
at our office instead of going for those
much-loved business trips taking
holidays in Big Sur rather than flying
off to New York for the weekend
opting to buy stuff that hasn't been
Arif raided in from the other side of
the planet or driving a more efficient
car if you can't get there by bicycle
but these aren't things that you know
not heard before for me the intermediate
more important step is that we need to
come to terms with our complex difficult
and above all ambiguous relationship
with oil as individual consumers and
that is that oil is a substance that
both creates and destroys many of the
things that we hold dear on complex
issues such as these my hope is that we
go from visceral black-and-white
reactions to responding from a place of
full awareness my hope is that the next
time you see oil you react as an
intrigued consumer and see oil in full
color thank you